LORAS WITH THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION.
BILL, LET ME START WITH YOU.
EVEN IF WHAT VAN AND THE WHITE
HOUSE ARE SAYING IS ALL TRUE,
THE SCARE TACTICS HAVE NOT
WORKED.
>> BEFORE YOU GO ON --
>> LET ME FINISH MY QUESTION.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACTS.
>> NO, LET ME FINISH MY
QUESTION, BILL.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS POLLING.
ONLY ABOUT 36% OF AMERICANS
THINK GLOBAL WARMING IS A
SERIOUS THREAT TO OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
NOW, AGAIN, LET ME PAUSE IT.
EVERYTHING THAT VAN AND THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE SAID IS TRUE,
HOWEVER, THE SCARE TACTICS HAVE
NOT WORKED, AND DON'T YOU NEED
PUBLIC CONSENSUS TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THIS?
>> SO, HOW DO YOU WANT TO GET
PUBLIC CONSENSUS, BY SAYING THAT
IT'S NOT HAPPENING, THAT IT'S
NOT SERIOUS, THAT SHORELINES
AREN'T FLOODING?
>> NO, I WANT YOU TO ADVISE THE
POLITICIANS, BECAUSE WHATEVER
THEY ARE DOING, WHATEVER VAN IS
DOING TO SCARE THE PUBLIC, IS
NOT CHANGING PUBLIC --
>> INFORM THE PUBLIC, BUT GO
RIGHT AHEAD.
>> TELL US HOW TO USE THE
SCIENCE TO ACTUALLY CHANGE
PUBLIC CONSENSUS.
>> GET THE MESSAGE OUT.
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS.
IF YOU LIVE IN OKLAHOMA, WHERE
TORNADOS HAVE WIPED YOUR TOWN
OUT A COUPLE TIMES, AND YOU
CHOSE ALASKA, WHICH IS REMOTE,
GENERALLY, BUT REMEMBER
HURRICANE SANDY, THE BOTTOM HALF
OF MANHATTAN WAS FLOODED.
THE ECONOMIC EFFECT OF THAT
ALONE IS ENORMOUS, LET ALONE THE
REBUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE'RE IN THE DEVELOPED WORLD
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GET ON THE
HIGHWAY AND DRIVE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SAY MOVING A
HIGHWAY FOUR FEET, DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE VERY MUCH, BUT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF TONS
OF ROAD THAT HAVE TO BE LIFTED
AND THAT ENERGY HAS TO COME FROM
SOMEWHERE, AND THAT'S JUST THE
START OF THINGS.
WHEN WE START HAVING CROP
FAILURES AND THE DROUGHT THAT'S
IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUES, THE
ECONOMIC COSTS --
>> YOU CAN LOOK AT THESE THINGS
AND THE CLIMATE REALITIES AND
EVEN THIS NCA REPORT SAYS THE
TREND ON TORNADOS ISN'T TERN,
THE IPPC REPORT SAYS THE
HURRICANE REPORT ISN'T
UNCERTAIN.
I'M NOT A DENIER OR SKEPTIC,
CLIMATE IS CHANGING, YES,
MANMADE EMISSIONS ARE SOME PART
TO THAT, BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THESE TRENDS.
THE OBSERVED DATA DOESN'T PROVE
THAT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS, THESE GREEN HOUSE
GAS REGULATIONS COMING DOWN,
PROHIBITING BUILDING NEW
COAL-FIRE POWER PLANTS WILL MAKE
US LESS EQUIPPED TO HANDLE THESE
PROBLEMS, WHETHER THEY ARE MORE
FREQUENT OR NOT.
>> LET'S START WITH WE DON'T
AGREE ON THE FACTS.
THIS THIRD REPORT CAME OUT
SAYING IT'S VERY SERIOUS, YOU
SAY, NO, RIGHT?
THERE'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
PROBLEM, S.E.
THE SCIENCE, THE RESEARCHERS SAY
YES.
>> NOT ALL THE RESEARCHERS.
EVEN THE IPPC SAYS THERE'S NO
FREQUENCY OR INTENSITY WHEN IT
COMES TO HURRICANES.
>> HURRICANE, SMHURRICANE.
>> IT'S INCREASING AT A SLOWER
RATE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
WE'VE HAD ARCTIC ICE GLOBALLY
INCREASING.
>> BILL, ISN'T IT A PROBLEM WHEN
SCIENCE GUYS ATTEMPT TO BULLY
OTHER PEOPLE?
I MEAN, NICK HERE HAD TO SAY,
I'M NOT A DENIER.
HE HAD TO GET IT UP, I'M NOT A
DENIER, BECAUSE REALLY, THE
SCIENCE GROUP HAS TRIED TO SHAME
ANYONE WHO DARES QUESTION THIS,
AND THE POINT I'M